dans la région de Belgorod les centres
d'hébergement se remplissent à mesure
que les frappes s'intensifient la région
est située à quelques kilomètres de la
frontière ukrainienne
nous nous sommes préparés à l'avance à
une telle situation suite à la décision
du gouvernement dans la seule ville de
Belgorod 6 centre d'hébergement
temporaires ont été mis en place
celui-ci peut abriter 1250 personnes
de la frontière aurait été la cible de
tir d'artillerie elles auraient fait une
dizaine de blessés Moscou affirme que
l'armée ukrainienne tente d'envahir la
région à 150 km plus au nord la ville de
Koursk aurait-elle été ciblée par des
drones tout s'abattu selon les autorités
locales mais l'intensité des frappes
reste bien plus importante de l'autre
côté de la frontière notamment à Kiev ou
les habitants ici réfugiés dans le métro
victorythme des sirènes d'alerte et des
explosions
la Russie multiplie les attaques
aériennes nocturnes dans la nuit de
jeudi à vendredi plus de 30 drones
émises russes ont été interceptés
au-dessus de la capitale d'après le
gouvernement mais les chutes de débris
sont aussi meurtrières elles ont tué
trois personnes à qui elles jeudi matin